okay guys in this problem a contractor
is bringing in fill material to a 10
acre job site and placing it to an
initial depth of 5 ft however the fill
material is completely saturated and
begins to drain the moment it leaves the
trucks and is placed on the site the
soil has a void ratio of
0.4 if the contractor needs to collect
and remove all of the water draining
from the soil that is placed how much
will it cost them assuming collection
costs are 5050 cents per
gallon so the first thing we're going to
do here is we're going to need to find
conversions for two things one is acres
to feet in case you've forgotten it and
two cubic feet to gallons and it's okay
if you don't recognize this right away
when you're reading the problem the
thing to know is just that you need to
go to section
1.2 of the civil engineering reference
manual that I'm using and you should be
able to get these conversion factors
pretty easily so let's start solving the
problem so step one down here is going
to be finding first the amount of
saturated soil that the contractor
brought with
them so it's a 10 acre job site and our
unit conversion for acres to feet is
going to be sorry acres to square feet I
should have said that before
anyway it's going to be
43560 square ft per acre and the
contractor is placing this fill material
to an initial depth of 5
ft so that means that 5 ft of saturated
soil is being
placed and this calculation here 10
acres *
43560 Square ft per acre * 5 ft
should give us about 2,
178,000 cubic feet of saturated
soil now the problem states that the
soil has a void ratio of
0.4 if we remember our basic Geotech in
a column of soil with the whole value
being equal to one the soil will have a
void ratio and the water and air will
have a void ratio as well now since the
soil is completely saturated we know
that there is no air so there's only
Soil and Water so in this case
0.4 of the total one is going to be
water and all that means for us in Step
2 is that we're going to multiply the
cubic feet of saturated soil from above
by
0.4 and this will give us
87120 cubic feet of
water for step three we can do our final
unit conversion to figure out how many
gallons this is and then figure out how
much it
costs and our conversion is 1 gallon to
134 cubic feet
and then we could multiply this by 50
cents per
gallon and do this all at
once this is going to cost about
$3,250,000
which is very close to answer number two
here
and that's all it takes to solve this
problem